this is an early test video for one of
the white spikes from 2021's the
tomorrow war
but it's very different from what the
viewer sees in the finished movie
the creatures are not really conducive
to having an actor inside to get here
spectromotion built a moving animatronic
powered by motors known as servos which
was used as a reference for the visual
effects team and even ended up in some
of the final shots
movement is what really sells any
animatronic character in a movie so
roboticists like mark zutrakian work
tirelessly to nail down realistic
motions
like these gigantic troll hands from
2013's hansel and gretel witch hunters
which needed to move nimbly enough to
convincingly pick up objects and throw
punches the performer who played edward
the troll wore two animatronic hands but
they were so large that the performer's
hands only reached the troll's wrists as
he moved the hands around the subtle
finger motions were created with radio
controlled hobby servos like you'd find
in a model plane each hand had 10 servos
spread throughout the fingers each
finger actually has two degrees of
freedom that means that there's a base
knuckle like this and then there's these
two phalanges here that can also move
you can map each axis of these joysticks
to specific joints in this case you're
mapping them to the finger joints
so depending on how i map those
you can optimize the hand for doing
different actions
toggling one joystick created a gesture
or a point running controls
simultaneously for the thumb and index
fingers as seen in this early test video
created a pinching motion used to lift
up this small object the work done on
top of the servos is equally important
no matter how sophisticated the radio
controls the movements would feel off if
each muscle and joint that made up a
hand wasn't in exactly the right place
one motion mark observed in his own
hands compression in this area the upper
palm had to line up perfectly with the
knuckles to achieve this mark worked
with spectral motion sculptors from the
start to make sure their model went hand
in hand with his servos the mechanical
design starts with the sculpture we can
see these big wrinkly knuckles let's put
a little tension on there like it would
be in real life
so that joint appears to be right here
and anatomically
that puts it right behind this big fat
pad right here so the anatomy really has
to be based on reality and that's where
the best mechanism designs start from
the ways in which the mechanics and the
outer layers work together are even more
important when it comes to conveying
emotions in the face
that's where soft mechanics come in
these are cables embedded in the outer
layer of animatronics soft mechanics are
often used for animatronics that don't
have traditional bones and joints like
the petals on the demogorgon's head that
mark operated for stranger things or
edward the troll's tongue
and in 2006's lady in the water mark and
his team wanted to give the wolf-like
scrunt an angry snarl
here are the sprint's hard mechanics
this piece here both pulls the nose back
and lifts it up at the same time
but those hard mechanics had to work
hand in hand with the softer elements of
the wolf's face
like these lips that pull up and expose
the fangs and it looks a little odd here
without the skin on but when the skin's
on it looks very realistic the skin
itself posed a problem however unlike a
real wolf the scrunt had a coat made of
grass
so one of the most expressive parts of
the face the eyebrows weren't coming
through that thick layer
they're like these two points and they
move around and they have whiskers
sticking out of them so mark actually
strayed from reality and based its
eyebrows on human eyebrows it was
necessary to punch up that expression
that there's no ambiguity about it when
this thing is snarling and it's angry
that those brows are selling that the
creature is angry when moving down to
the skrunt's tail mark encountered a
very tricky motion challenge cascading
these complex motions are used for
movements like wagging or the curling of
a tentacle
so mark linked up servos in a chain then
created a delay so each servo moved a
little bit after the one before it
causing a chain reaction down the piece
the more servos the smoother the motion
mark first achieved this effect when
building samael's tentacle main in
2004's hellboy he realized that the
cascading quality could be retrofitted
to the scrunt's tail
when the delay is set to zero the tail
curls up crank up the delay and it wags
like a real tail the cascade controller
also works on fingers
by distributing motion from finger to
finger mark created the illusion of
finger drumming on king balor's hand
from 2008's hellboy 2.
despite their amazing range radio
controlled servos have their limits
so one of the things about robotics that
most people don't know is that
pound-for-pound robots have one tenth of
the strength of humans or animals as you
can see here the scrunch can look side
to side but it can't tilt its head
because they couldn't fit the servos
needed in its neck
those servos are great but
they're fairly simplistic in the way
they're controlled and they just do one
thing you have to make some decisions
about what you're going to leave out
but fast forward to 2021's the tomorrow
war this terrifying white spike
animatronic that mark helped create can
tilt its head thanks to major
technological advancements the key here
was a modern digital industrial servo
unlike the large servos used on the
scrunt mark says these ones are
specifically designed to fit inside of a
robot without sacrificing their strength
this thing is ridiculously strong so we
can put a big heavy head on the end of
this thing and it can it can handle it i
can command these with high precision
which has really not been possible prior
to that this six axis module has six
degrees of freedom
it can turn
it can tilt and it can also shift and it
can change length too which is very
unusual like edward and the scrunt the
white spike is moved by joysticks
this time mark used a software system he
built called the motion synthesizer
the functions are represented by little
boxes with patch cords connected
together so
by connecting the nodes together in
patch cords it's really easy to
visualize what's happening from top to
bottom while the module's tilt motion
looks rough at first once mark adds
filters to it it becomes smoother and
therefore more lifelike take some of
that filtering off and it can go much
faster as i crank this up to around 60
you can see the
movement of the puppet component is now
becoming very fluid no matter how much
more powerful the technology gets the
finished product is only as good as the
brains behind the operation you can
always get the puppet working but you
have to get it working at the exact
moment it's supposed to be working
sometimes it doesn't always work out
that way so
you gotta adapt